the u.s. skill scouts are warning
parents not to encourage children to hug
guests this Christmas the organization
says that the hugs could lead to other
types of physical affection and that the
child themselves should decide whether
or not to give a hug Girl Scout
psychologist Andrea
bastiana archibald says that it teaches
an important life lesson sadly we know
that some adults prey on children and
teaching your daughter about constant
early on can help her understand her
rights know when lines have been crossed
and went to go to you for help well the
u.s. Girl Scouts were founded by
Juliette Gordon low one hundred one
hundred and six years ago they've been
around for a while they call themselves
a leadership development organization
promoting confidence courage and
character it all sounds very good let's
discuss this now with psychology expert
Gina Loudon a women's rights advocate
Reece Everson great to have you on
ladies first to you if I may Reese could
there really be worrying consequences if
a girl hugs our aunt or our grandparents
at Christmas well here's the question
does the child decide on their own that
they want to participate in the embrace
yes it's a hug yes it's the holiday
season we're all feeling very festive
however children have to learn
self-determination self autonomy and
they have to realize that they're in
control of their bodies if you don't
teach a child early on that they are in
control of their bodies and that they
are in control of their boundaries then
they're subject to later on not be able
to set healthy boundaries and if a child
does not sell so you get a get into the
habit of setting healthy boundaries then
what you have is a person who's open to
issues like sexual harassment in the
workplace and sexual assault and not
being able to properly tell people
what's acceptable for them Gina what do
you think of this is it okay to tell
parents you know you shouldn't encourage
your kids to hug family members
absolutely not I think that this is all
about communication and that's the key
if parents are having the
age-appropriate conversations with their
children that are well documented and
data-driven
then they shouldn't have to have any
sorts of concerns first of all I
wouldn't put my child in the presence of
anyone who I was concerned might be
doing something to harm them and I would
have had those conversations with with
my children far before we're facing a
holiday or any sort of gift-giving
situation where they might be couldn't
put in an uncomfortable position having
said that if you have discussed these
matters with your children I certainly
hope and encourage all parents to do so
when a child is given a gift they should
be gracious about it
whatever is family appropriate different
families have certain different levels
of affection but at least a warm thank
you and and and you know as I think was
mentioned in some of the some of the
suggestions may be at least a high five
or a fist bump something like that but
we do want to raise our children to be
gracious recipients and I think that
anything that takes that away is
completely ignoring the conversations
that should be taking place between
parents and their children on a daily
basis research you mentioned here's the
fact the matter what are you doing girls
are sexually abused one in four girls
are sexually abused before they turn 18
I would say about 34 the statistics say
about 30 percent of the sexual abuse
that happens to a child happens by a
family member so here's the fact of the
matter
children are often not safe around
people that we would like to thank our
healthy people and unfortunately we
don't always know as adults what the
appetite a person may have for a child
in a sexual situation so to say to a
child Oh auntie Joe or uncle Joe gave
you a gift give them a hug if the child
is energetically showing you
apprehension you as a parent have to
take in and participate in a be aware of
the signs that are now you know being
presented to you and be aware of what
this child is trying to communicate if
it's nonverbal if it's apprehension if
it's concern or confusion then these are
things that we have to as parents be
very very kind
learn about parents aunts uncles and the
village that raise these children
because they the signs aren't always
completely verbal hey this guy is
creeping me out as an odd or uncle you
know you want children to be gracious in
receiving gifts but at the same time we
can't do it at the cost of their ability
to set healthy boundaries Genie what do
you think the Girl Scouts were we're
trying to achieve part of you know I get
I get a little bit concerned when I see
especially some of the more radical
feminist bent that the Girl Scouts have
taken on where they're perhaps saying
you know that you know girls don't need
to necessarily be taught to be gracious
I think they do I think boys do too we
all know that children are naturally
more into themselves naturally more self
focused than outwardly focused and some
children just are not naturally gracious
and that's something that's really
important for parents to teach respect
of elders is important for parents to
teach as well so as long as those
conversations are taking place and as
long as the most important conversation
is taking place and that is you should
never put your children in a situation
at a holiday given that 1 in 4 children
women are abused before 18 and there are
a lot of boys in that too we seem that
act like boys don't matter in the world
but actually as a mother of boys they do
matter to me and so the fact that
children are often sexually abused are
often sexually abused in family
situations these conversations need to
be taking long before any gifts are
exchanged and any expectation is made
and so once that gift is exchanged once
that kind deed is done I think it is
important because you as a parent have
determined that these people are safe
for your child to be around that the
child is taught respect and manners and
respect of elders and whatever whatever
the appropriate response is for that
child in that moment because some
children have an actual bent toward
inwardness and we need to teach our
children to be fortunately the parents
don't always know when a person is a
safe person or not unfortunately most
times when a person is being molested
the parents have no eye
if the grandfather uncle's molesting
them and so it the onus is on the
parents to be aware cognizant of what
catch I'll dis communicating and more
importantly we can't teach girls to put
grace before being able to protect and
set healthy boundaries and oftentimes
especially in this southern of Brando
and just across the country we teach
young ladies - oh thank you and and and
to make sure that they're always
pleasant and always presenting this kind
demeanor instead of saying someone has
offended me and this is not a healthy
situation and it allows young girls to
repeatedly find themselves in situations
where they're harmed because most women
who their boundaries have been broken by
you know sexual assault or rape of
course you know go on later on to become
another victim of rape later on in their
future so what we have to do is learn
that a person who doesn't learn these
boundaries early on will usually repeat
this and so it's imperative that before
we decide that grace is the most
important thing and that being grateful
I mean of course that's important but we
can't do that at the cost of teaching
young women what's safe for them and
knowing how to speak up and say you've
hurt me you've offended me I don't like
this I don't want to hug this person
energy matters to children and they
understand that way more than they may
understand the words they may not be
able to even verbalize why they feel
what they feel so we as a parenthood and
adults in the community have to
understand when a child says my energy
this doesn't sit well with me we have to
allow that to be okay
Jeanne you touched upon this do you
think there's a danger that by talking
about these boundaries and enforcing
them we're going to create children who
are afraid of physical contact
hmmm I think that's one concern I think
narcissism is a massive problem in our
society and I think leaving little boys
out of this conversation is particularly
offensive because I think that if I'm
not mistaken boys are more ripe for
sexual assault especially in childhood
than girls and so I don't know why we
leave 50% of the population out of this
conversation other than to sort of
assume some sort of superiority which is
bizarre to me but anyway yes we should
absolutely protect our children oh and
is that one in formal reasons for
self-respecting I didn't interrupt you
and I'd appreciate if you didn't
interrupt me thank you no one is saying
we should increases we're having a
conversation
it's called dialogue before well
actually you're talking over me no one's
saying that we should put graciousness
or respect for elders before protecting
our children but again if you decide
only to protect your child on a holiday
when they're already exposed to this
relative that they're uncomfortable
around the mistake has already made for
a lot of problems going forward and so I
would say that it's the other 364 days
of the year that parents need to be
listening and parenting and having these
conversations with their children so
that they never expose their children
now having said that I've been with many
parents who have you know encountered
horrible things like this
I myself have encountered horrible
things like this in my lifetime so I'm
not saying that anyone should be
lackadaisical about the cues that
children are taking but it is a balance
and it is something that is really
important and we're not going to solve
it by telling our little girl on
Christmas Day that she doesn't have to
say thank you to Grandma for her gift I
just don't think that that's that's when
we present that as a solution we're
missing out on what is really happening
here in my opinion and we're putting
children at greater danger and reefs
just to me unless you want to respond to
that I'll just move it on slightly you
know we talked about whether children
could grow up afraid of physical contact
do you think there's a danger just think
I become emotionally stunted as well if
a kid hears other children saying oh no
you mustn't hug grandmother it's not
right I was told this that you're going
to distance children from from relatives
absolutely nine it's all preposterous
first of all let's be clear we're
talking about girls specifically because
one in four girls compared to one in six
boys prior to the age of eighteen find
themselves victims of sexual assault
secondly we address the issue of setting
healthy boundaries that's the whole
point that the Girl Scouts is hoping to
drive home this is not about a lack of
gratitude this is not about a lack of
graciousness both of those are societal
norms that have to be taught and they're
very key and critical however as a
society we tend to pressure girls in
ways that we don't pressure boys if you
go to the toy stores you'll see girls
being given toys for learning how to
cook and play with baby dolls you'll see
boys be given toys on how to you know
build astronaut B astronauts and build
rocket ships and be construction workers
so there's a disparity on how we teach
and handle our girls Michelle Obama has
noted this as well so it's important
that when we do teach our girls that in
relating to other people maybe this is
your first time seeing this uncle or you
haven't seen him all year this person if
you feel something energetically I want
you to trust that why because as a part
as a mother your job is to teach your
child to be able to navigate the world
and you can't do that if you don't
properly teach the child how to trust
themselves a child can only trust
themselves if they understand that
something that I feel within myself
gives me cause for pause and if I have a
bit of concern that I should not embrace
physically this person because I don't
trust it then that's okay you have to be
able to teach a child how to navigate on
their own and that's issue number one so
grace wonderful love it hey Jack you got
a gift for Christmas tell tell your
uncle thank you thank you should be
sufficient if a young lady says that she
does not want to embrace and and give up
the control of her body then she has the
right to say so and we have to create a
environment where girls are okay saying
no here's why
we have that time I'm gonna have to
interrupt you there my my sincerest
apologies many thanks to you both ladies
psycho don't worry Gina loud and women's
rights 3-1 same to you both ladies
you